i know a lot of directors
who have
been in the industry for many many years
who
well let me rephrase they
want to be directors
they fantasize like myself they grew up
and they saw
back to the future or jurassic park as
kids and
went ah that's what i want to do i want
to create that and now they're editing
for reality television
or shooting wedding videos
and not doing
what they dreamed
you have to get experience directing
and if you were to ask yourself
how many hours have you actually spent
directing
like beyond this is not on set this is
not on set as a pa or editing or even
writing how many hours have you spent
actually directing
how many hours would that actually be
that is so vital because when you get
your shot when someone does open that
door for you you better hit the ground
running and know exactly how to do it
well
it's kind of a maddening thing to think
about right well i don't have any
experience directing how do i do that
well
you don't always need a camera one of
the things that i tried that really
transformed a lot of what i do
is i wanted to get better at working
with actors so i invited a couple of
actors to my studio i gave them a scene
from a play
i had no cameras and no lights and i
just had the two of them reading the
screen scene to each other
act out the scene and i tried to see if
i could get them to a better more
connected performance that's it
and it's important to say that this was
not a scene i wrote this is just a scene
out of a play that the actors just got
on the spot
reading through it
do the scene together
and it's so awkward and so hard for that
just the actors okay i'm seeing the
awkwardness i'm seeing the fact that
they're trying to read the lines and
remember what to say i'm seeing that
they're not connecting how can i make
them connect how do i do that
it is terrifying
it it i would have massive anxiety
before each time i would have them come
over to try it
um
but it changed everything for me because
now
because that's directing that's sitting
there in the chair for hours
all right actors
try holding hands and see if that helps
connect you more
or
sinking them into their environment
painting pictures for them imagining
that you're having a picnic on a blanket
right now and there's a storm cloud
coming and the rain pellets are just
starting to fall like feel the rain
smell how the ground is feeling and now
action
and see what happens this is all
directing and i would say that if you
don't have any hours doing it this is
one way that you can increase the amount
of work that you're doing so it's so
important and you have to can you have
to be very uh
relentless about it
constantly finding like if you find that
you're in this been in this business for
more than
i don't know
six eight years
and you've got
one short under your belt
it's
you it's time to step it up and figure
out a way to get something else done
um
another thing that i've done that's
helped me is
um i had a shoot once where it was just
a
little corporate thing
this shoe was on a friday we had a
little grip truck of grip and lighting
stuff in the truck well that couldn't
return the truck until monday so that
weekend
i took uh
the truck
with the camera that i'd rented and on a
saturday we just went and got a couple
actors and i wanted to experiment with
some intimate like a love story i'd
never tried that before
i'd never done like a love scene i
didn't know how to do it even but i got
some actors that i trusted and they
trusted me and we just
tried stuff and just you know i mean
like
a two a couple falling in love and just
what how to shoot intimacy you know and
just create this beautiful little love
story we didn't even have audio we just
had visuals
it's on it's on my reel it's just like
as something that we played with and
tried it's it's putting work out there
that is super important
because when the window comes and it
will there will come a time when someone
decides to give you a shot you got to
have something to show them you got to
have
some sort of real
they have to believe in you somehow
so
hopefully you're not trying to scramble
the night before to put something
together like
this is how you do it um
another way to be working
is you have to you have to aggressively
expand your network
now that
people hear that and they think the word
networking and
that is what i mean but that's not
totally what i mean i i think the better
way to phrase it would be
making more friends
usually when people think about
expanding their network they think about
going to a networking event which i
think is one of the worst places
i mean that can be great but it's one of
the hardest places to actually network
actually
builds your network i think one of a
really good place is actually a film
festival
and the key to
things like festivals screenings
things like that is not just meeting
someone at an event it's following up
so
my the feature i just shot
um
the reason one of the big the first
things that got going as far as got got
that feature off the ground was
me meeting the screenwriter at the
austin film festival
and
the only reason that i ever even got the
screenplay from him
so his name is dwayne warrell he was
speaking on a panel so i'm just an
audience member i didn't even have a
project in the festival i was just there
to attend to meet people to do exactly
what i'm talking about to aggressively
expand my friend network dwayne spoke on
this panel because he had written
uh it was an award-winning film through
amazon called the wall
uh
john cena's in it um
jason aaron aaron taylor johnson
guy from ass i'm blanking on his name
he's quicksilver anyway
directed by doug lyman who did the
bourne identity and mr mrs smith so wow
dwayne wow he wrote this wow what a guy
so you know i'm super intimidated but i
go up and i
introduce myself and
you know we hit it off okay but i made
sure to get his contact information so
that i could follow up with him later
which we did once we both got back to la
which is one of the reasons to live in
la because a lot of people live here
anyway
so we went out to dinner
and
that was where it was really important
to
just be
a person
not a desperate
you're so great duane i want to work
with you it was just
what do we have in common he likes
sports uh he like you know
he likes sci-fi action we just kind of
bonded over common interest and we
became good friends and then it was when
we had this connection then he sent me
the script for the abandon
and when i read it it was like
wow that's the best script i've ever
read
then i took that script
went to another film festival and i met
a couple of producers
from the i did the same thing same exact
thing met them
saw that they had made a couple of films
that were lower budget after the
festival was over i followed up
said hey would you like to go to coffee
sometime we could chat about whatever
ken made a connection hung out with the
guy said you know i just came across
this script that i really liked
passed it to him he read it and said
let's do it let's make a project all of
that came about because of just
aggressively making sure i was
constantly meeting people um
i will put on task lists each week to
meet more industry people usually it's
by a month like this month i need to
meet three new people make three new
friends
uh
and i would say
i don't limit it to has to be a producer
or an agent
um
it could be anybody in the industry
really because you just
don't know
who
ironically i i made a friend in a
writing class that i'm in
this is a super nice guy that's really
humble
soft-spoken guy and he
i let i learned he just moved to l.a so
i was like
oh he just moved to l.a he's a director
like me he's right a director guy and
just just seemed like a nice guy and i
kind of felt bad for him like oh you
probably don't know anybody in l.a you
want to grab a coffee sometime yeah sure
so we went out to coffee me and my wife
and just hung out with him for a bit
like what does your wife do oh you know
she's an actress like oh yeah i think i
said something like trying to make it in
the big time huh
[Music]
and i'm like well man it'd be fun to
hang out with all of you know maybe go
on a double date or whatever you know
just being friends just again expanding
the network
being friends making connections growing
the thing i said
you know what we're having to cook out
at my place you want to come over like
you you know you're new to town you
probably don't know anybody
come on out meet some friends it'd be
great to have you
he shows up
and his wife
gets out of the car and she is like
very a very known golden globe winning
actress and i'm just like
he he i had no idea who his wife like it
was it's hilarious thinking about it but
it all came about
because of this
constant push to continue to make more
friends grow the network because that is
how
jobs get made people
the jobs that rarely don't happen
because of the meeting
they happen because you're hanging out
at someone's birthday party and we're
like dude you know what
i've got this idea for a comedy horror
we should you want to do it we should do
it like
that happens all of the time all the
time that's how you get things made is
by having all these friends if the only
friends that you have
are your mom
and just your couple of buddies you went
to film school with you it's gonna be a
lot more difficult for you to actually
get past where you are you have to push
beyond that boundary
what about um nepotism though we hear
we see in the comments we hear from
people you know all the time that you
really can't get any meaningful work
unless you're related to someone
i have heard that myself um
nepotism is a real thing um
especially if you live in a big hub city
like la new york
um
and
you're competing against kevin costner's
kids you know or whatever spielberg's
son who wants to whatever that is the
reality that's who you're dealing with
well
i think it's really easy to fall back on
that excuse and say well i can't because
i'm not anyone's son
i grew up
far away from hollywood now i'm not
directing marvel films at the moment but
that doesn't mean i'm not working
right so
you
your future and your career is something
you have to grab a hold of we can make a
thousand excuses all day long about the
reasons why we're not making it
um if that's what you're doing with your
creative time then that's probably why
you're not making it
yes
good for them you know steven
spielberg's son i don't know a statement
good for that guy like he's got a
connection and a good in
well
then maybe you should
become friends with someone like that
you know maybe you should
find a way to make
invent your own nepotism you know like
become best friends with a showrunner if
you can you know like that's how
because look to be honest like i would
function the same way we like to like
throw the blame on this oh it's all
politics and it's all who you know yeah
and i do the same thing when i hire a
project
and i need a dp who do you think i'm
going to call
do i call
some demo reel that i've seen online of
a dp i've never met or am i going to
call
you know sally who i know is awesome and
she's super talented and we've worked
that's what i'm going to call
because that's how we're all like that
right we all want to work with our
friends and we all want to have this
solid team of people
so it goes back to just
making sure that you are connected to
the right people i mean that's really it
sounds simple but that's really
and rather than um
making excuses as to oh i'm not
connected to anyone i'm not so-and-so's
relative
i think that's just an excuse to not go
out and actually do the scary work of
becoming
friends with
you know these people
my personal humble opinion
but so when you've been to networking
events
it's it's kind of reminds me of like you
know these like singles dances back in
like the 80s and 90s that i would hear
people go to and you know like okay hey
i'm here to meet someone and there's
like this weird desperation and
awkwardness whereas if you're at a film
festival or taking a writing class
you're engaged in something else
and then if naturally
something happens or you approach
somebody that's a speaker it just it
seems like there's just a different way
there's less pressure maybe
yeah the nice thing about yeah because
networking events
i'm not saying never go because there
there is value in them but it is exactly
like that it's speed dating and it's
generally
you
everyone is coming up to each other
going
how can you advance my career it's a
very self-centered way to meet people
it's i mean imagine if you were trying
to date somebody and you were going i'm
really looking for a wife or a husband
i mean
the other person is going to be like uh
sure slow down there cowboy like
i don't even know your name right what
do you do jason that's right yes yeah
it's and i'm looking at your watch and
the car you're driving
you know if i'm it happens you know and
i'm not even like
anybody and if people find out i'm a
director
and then they're an actor
ah you're a director like you could just
feel the energy of like this
uh it's a it's a hard place
because everyone is essentially feeling
the same way now and if i were in that
same plane and i've got actors coming at
me from this way but i look over there
and there's a
an investor
now that's you doing oh
hey you want to make a movie you know
it's that same i mean it's human nature
yeah
it is human so
i think finding i think
in if you are at the networking event
there is a positive way to go about it
and i think that would be
to try to remove the desperation from it
go to the event without
the mindset of i have to get a job
just like you wouldn't go on a date
saying i have to find a partner
it just puts so much pressure on this
precious little connection that you're
trying to make
if you just remove that from the
equation and just say i'd like to just
make a friend
that is so much easier because you know
oddly enough some of the best
connections i've made at things like
that are usually someone like
the the person that's serving the hors
d'oeuvres you know
like hit it off with so-and-so and like
isn't this whole thing such a crock i
know man people come down here they're
so desperate
what do you do oh i'm you know my name's
johnny and i i'm a dp and i actually
just i'm just doing this for extra work
what you are no way you know and then
all of a sudden your friends
oh it's so much easier
to do that do it that way to take the
pressure off this desperation
but a film festival or writing class
those are great because the focus is not
on you as much it's on
either their film or your film or
writing class is a good one because it's
like you're focusing on a craft of like
getting better you're meeting other
people also with similar goals they're
all there to improve their craft and and
driving towards this direction not this
direction i mean yes we're all trying to
make it but we're all looking this way
and you just happen to be looking at the
person next to you and you're just kind
of becoming this
making a bond that way so it's a much
easier way to make friends and
to build a team